foreign
is known to have some of the biggest
fits on the red carpet they're big not
that big but big we're gonna break down
five of his biggest fits and see which
one is the most biggest the biggest
biggest
okay so this is your man Timothy at the
Golden Globes 2020. the look is Louis
Vuitton one of the earlier collections
Virgil did he went with the harness I'm
not such a big fan of the harness to be
honest maybe this is a nice one you know
you definitely want to make sure that
you're looking at something that has a
little bit of flash to it I think the
length of the pants are good I think
they could have been a slightly longer
do you think that they're the right
length 2020 because you know the joints
got a little bit longer in 22.
um they could have been a little I think
a little bit a little longer I'm not mad
at him it's a booth to the nice and
clean the shininess of the Boost the
patent leather on the boots I think goes
back nicely to the harness yeah we get a
detail shot please
how do you feel about the band collar I
feel like it's the right move I love the
band color yeah it's my jam I think it's
fly I think the offset button actually
makes it a little bit more elegant what
do you think of the strap coming off the
harness I think the strap could have
been trimmed a little bit it seems a bit
long yeah and I get it it's a signature
but I don't know I'm not a big harness
fan so I would say it's a black belt
move but again like it depends on what
the event is you know what you're trying
to achieve yeah I'm gonna disagree with
you it depends on the person this on
someone else I don't know you need to
graduate to the harness you can't start
there yeah seriously which I mean kind
of makes it the definition of a big fit
yeah let's see how this ranks on the
board
I noticed our first look but I'm gonna
go ahead and put it here it's definitely
not the biggest I think we can go bigger
I think we can go bigger
this is Timothy Venice Film Festival
2022. now this is a fit I happen to be
there and when he popped out of this the
crowd went wild and I was like what and
then I was like okay yeah you need to
have some serious shoulder muscles yeah
to pull this off yeah to wear this is
bold like oh both that is bold crazy
crazy and not a lot of accessories no
but you kind of the Rings here the arms
are the accessories actually I think I
mean no watch no just the two little
Rings right there the halter top and the
scarf are actually all made of one so
it's not an accessory I think we can
call it an accessory yeah a built-in
accessory also wearing red on the red
carpet if he was wearing some version of
a red shoe it would be full Overkill
yeah the fact that he went with the
black Cuban heel boot gives definitely a
smart move in terms of the fit not the
bigness of the fit yeah but the
smallness of the fit on the pants I
think the Hem could have been a bit
flatter I think that there's something
interesting about the wrinkles and the
holes okay I think it adds a little bit
of vibe and like slight ruggedness in
like it's like a glove like you're
wearing these pants if we were to look
at a detail of this oh is this a silk
shantong I like it even more now
shantung is a woven fabric usually made
of different thicknesses of silk we
think about the Ray-Bans I think the
Ray-Bans the Flies a little cat eye I
think it's a surprising choice for Red
Carpet you would think maybe Tom Ford
designer
something like that I think Timothy has
established himself as someone who is
Not Afraid yeah to go for it yeah no one
can really do this no this way no 95 of
the bigness of a fit comes down to
attitude let's take this to the board
foreign
that's a very big fit I mean the
disparity between fit one and two right
now is pretty major release fabric
biggest fit it's like kind of kind of
big it's a tremendous fit yeah
tremendous no arms back out
okay so we got Timmy at the Met Gala
2021 so this is in America lexicon of
fashion okay you see America in the
Converse that I was just about to say
from a context perspective that really
makes it make more sense because I'm
gonna say that this is not my favorite
fit yeah and it's because I don't love
the converse you've already got the
sweatpants yep you've got the cropped
double-breasted jacket not mad at none
of that not mad at either of those
things particularly because it balances
out right you've got the cover buttons
which is very formal yep you've got the
jewelry on the sweatpants and then you
come down here yeah and it's still
casual you know I want like boom boom
boom I want like balance something here
that anchors it to the top I respect the
youth aspect of wearing that at the
bottom but fit wise I don't know it's a
mullet of a look you know like it's
definitely business in the front yeah a
little bit too much party down here for
me but the crop of the jacket I think
definitely allows for there to be more
volume at the bottom I think that that's
an interesting way of looking at it yeah
it's just too much bump down here yeah
that's a 1920s Cartier Broach right
there okay so he went into the archives
for that oh now this is interesting
they've got the white All-Star on the
trucks does that change your nope
opinion okay
I won't say that from the back it looks
a little better it feels cleaner still
not my favorite fit I like the cut of
the jacket personally I like cropped
jackets now generally speaking if you
saw a jacket this cropped it would be
paired with a pair of high-waisted pants
exactly right and like the volume is
right yep to wear with a jacket like
that yeah I think you can balance out
casual wear and formal wear I think
but overall it's a Vibe let's take this
to the board
so me
there's elements there but but I agree
it may be my least favorite I haven't
decided yet oh okay I think we could
leave it there for now tell me if you
think
I don't know I don't know listen to me
this fit
is less big than that fit I mean we
still got a way to go yeah I think that
we have more to see before we can decide
we need more vets okay Timmy given a
little clavicle chest right okay chest
up I mean I think this is another
example of your boy showing skin where a
lot of people would be uncomfortable
doing so so this is a woman's Louis
Vuitton collection jacket okay you got
the lace inserts here yep definitely got
a little bit of it right there yeah you
know I'm not a big fan of blazers or
jackets without shirts it's a Vibe it's
a look he pulls it off for sure let's go
to the pants we've got another pair of
crop trousers and another pair of boots
getting close to a Cuban heel Cuban heel
is a stacked heel on a boot they call it
a Cuban heel or a flamenco heel because
it was what the dancers wore I like the
pants I think that length is good I
think they could have come down a little
bit but I still like it the top is very
let's call it genderless but leaning
towards a baroque feeling it's a little
MJ actually okay well you know that's a
good little MJ but with like a little
turtle neck ruffle yeah probably but
that sounds like Prince when you think
about the necklace with the choker
aspect once again Cartier I like this I
think that could have been something
else like another chain exactly I mean
you're already not wearing a shirt yeah
like you might as well wear a grip of
chains
yeah a little Mr T action yeah there's a
little Mr T action yeah yeah yeah what
if we gave him some glasses I think you
need to be careful right you got a lot
of sequins and things going on with the
jacket yeah you got all the Rings yeah
but then once you add the glasses yeah
yeah I know are you then going to fall I
just like drawing on this thing overall
big fit it's a big fit I dig it I dig it
I think it belongs there so far of the
ones here yes yeah yeah I actually still
don't agree with you with that and that
I gotta I gotta give this props I mean
like I said it's not my favorite but I
think it's a bit bold I think it's a bit
bold to wear to the Met Gala the Blazer
is well tailored I like the sweatpants
separately I like the little jewelry
yeah you think that this is a bigger fit
objectively yeah than the harness yeah
he took a chance on this one so I'm
gonna I'm gonna give it more okay
the final fit bones and all I didn't
even notice that at first we like that
okay Timothy bones this is Alexander
McQueen boots would be as well your boy
likes a high Chelsea Boot and a high pan
yeah again no shirt but it's different
because it's covered so it's a little
bit different my question is is this a
styling technique to have one of the
lapels pop and the other one not or is
that the way the jacket is constructed I
think that's the way the jacket is
constructed I like the sunglasses yeah
same sunglasses this is definitely a
similar style I mean at least you know
what you like you know you know it works
on your face yeah okay what do you think
about the Rings I think the Rings are
good though how white dominant secondary
it doesn't matter I think it's good that
they're on one hand versus two halves a
little more Cartier action oh he's a
friend of the house he's a friend of the
house I'll be your friend Cartier
Cartier I have an empty hand yeah what's
up every look that he's done that we've
looked at is monochromatic wearing
things that have no variation yeah in
color be it black with like a white
shirt or whatever creates space within
the look half the bottom even the shoes
are white on this one so this is like
extra extra yeah this is fly yeah this
is my fly it's my flight that's a lot of
checks yeah I like to write okay so it's
a double-breasted jacket in theory
because of the way it's closed but it
has only one button the less buttons you
have on a jacket sort of lends itself to
feeling more formal you got cleaner
lines look at the diamond on the little
dog bones yeah that's a Vivian Westwood
choker Vivian
my neck is clean this is at the bones
and all Premiere not so subtle because
this diamond Bones on your neck and he
knows he knows look at that he's smiling
he's like you got it you got it mobilize
me I think the jewelry is fly yeah it
gives it Dimensions textures what do you
think about the boots in general I think
the boots go with the suit I don't know
whether those white boots without that
suit like if he was wearing like camo
pants and like uh hoodies nah you
shouldn't even say such things
is it the biggest fit
gonna have to say that the red is the
biggest fit so this is the second
biggest fan I think it's the second
biggest fit you like this one more than
you like the sequence you got to give
our man here props I mean this is what
happens
this is the biggest fish guns out sun's
out I think it's the biggest fit it's
the biggest so I'm gonna put it at the
end
do you think this is the second biggest
fish by far the second biggest fit I
would agree yeah I would agree
I still think that this is my least big
fit and it is killed for me by the shoes
that being said I understand your point
of view and I'm happy to leave it no no
no no no no maybe I agree with you
foreign
big some more bigger some more bigger
ish some more double extra large
triple extra large PhD biggest fit PhD
has a PHD fit yeah that's right that's
right biggest fit
[Music]